first of all welcome everybody uh i am
very pleased to be here to
talk about this program and i'll also
specifically tell you about
uh you know the drug discovery and the
development aspects that we will be
talking about
uh from what i just heard from sujit
this seems like a very exciting program
uh from a person who is willing to learn
about the
nuances of drug discovery i see that
there's a beautiful blend of theoretical
as well as practical knowledge that you
will gain
so i i really commend uh omics
for putting together such a beautiful
program
let me introduce myself first
so my name is uday saxena and as
sujeet said i am co-founder of a startup
biotech company called
reagene biosciences
i have a phd and a postdoc
like a lot of people who are in research
in
cell molecular biology and pharmacology
i started my career in a drug
industry in a company called park davis
pfizer in the u.s
and i was part of the team that
discovered a drug called lipitor
uh some of you might know it as an
autostatin
the brand name is lipitor this is a drug
that lowers
uh total body cholesterol and is used to
prevent heart diseases
uh the interesting thing about this
particular drug that i
i really am excited to uh tell you about
is the fact that this was the largest
selling
drug to date that has been known
uh to humans so the peak sales of their
drug were between 17 to 20
billion dollars a year so it was really
uh
what in our industry we call a huge
blockbuster
from there on i went to do a startup
company in the u.s called
atherogenics where i was head of r d
and we took an idea all the way
into clinical trials i then became the
chief scientific
officer for dr reddy's which as you or
some of you may know is one of the
largest
indian pharma companies based out of
hyderabad
and after that i have become an
entrepreneur and
doing a startup company myself
so so that's about myself i am part of
an organization
called faba and faba is a
not-for-profit organization that brings
together
it's called the federation of asian
biotechnology associations the whole
idea is to bring together
uh different biotechnology bodies from
india as well as enabling neighboring
asian countries and share knowledge
and faba academy which is actually a
it's it's something that has been
launched by faba to educate young people
in the nuances of drug discovery so
we are currently in partnership with
omics right now and very excited to be
able to participate in this
let me tell you how drug discovery works
and also want to tell you what's the
benefit of some
for people like you to be going through
this course so
first of all uh i don't know how many of
you know this
drug discovery is an extremely long
process
it takes an average of 12 to 15 years
from having an
idea to all the way to bringing a drug
to the market
so it's a very long process the other
thing about
drug discovery is that it's very
expensive
the current estimates of bringing a new
drug to the market
is about a billion to two billion
dollars that's how much money
the company a pharma company has to
spend
before they can successfully launch a
drug
on the market so not only is it time
consuming
it's also a very expensive process so
why am i telling you this the reason i'm
telling you
this is the more knowledge we can have
about the idea that you want to launch a
drug on
the more likely it is that you're going
to be successful
most of the drugs are based around
protein targets and you will learn a lot
about protein targets in the program
that's been
put together and so it the idea would
start from saying
okay this is a protein that's involved
in say alzheimer's
and we need to block its activity say if
it's an enzyme
so up front you need to know everything
about that protein
enzyme its crystal structure its docking
you know the whole nine yards so the
more information
you have about your target protein
the more likely it is that you're going
to be successful
in using that to launch a product so the
reason i'm telling you and emphasizing
that
is this program appears to have all
elements that are needed to successfully
choose a target validate a target
understand how it works and then design
drugs around it so
this program really to to my knowledge
is one of the more extensive
programs i've seen that will educate you
on right from the beginning of drug
discovery which is how do you choose a
protein target
right so you'll learn that once you
learn that you have to design
drugs against it and you will also learn
some of that in this
uh suji talked about a hit to a lead
so a hit is nothing but your initial
drug candidates that you have and then
off the thousand that you may have you
have to
then whittle it down to maybe five or
ten molecules
that you choose forward so from a hit of
thousand you go to lead which is five
how do you do that there's actually a
very very well thought out process that
we go through in the industry to do that
and in this program you're going to
learn about that as well
hit to lead and sujit has already talked
about that
then the drug moves into animal proof of
concept features you have to demonstrate
if it is alzheimer's you have to
recreate alzheimer's in an animal model
and show your lead candidates actually
provide any therapeutic benefits so
you'll learn some of that as well in
najeet kamats lecture
you learn about protein validation and
how drug discovery is taken from
selecting a target all the way to
establishing proof of concept
the final and the most expensive part of
drug discovery it's what is known as
clinical trials
clinical trials are important because
the drugs we design
are eventually consumed by human beings
so there are two things that regulatory
bodies such as the united states food
and drug
administration wants from you
if you are a former company you have to
demonstrate to them
that the drug that you have designed is
not only going to be therapeutic which
means it's efficacious
and protect against alzheimer's but it
also has to be
safe it's like a pilot right a pilot not
only has to learn how to fly a plane but
it has to be done
safely the reason that is important is
because
a lot of human lives are our state
similarly
in the drug discovery and development
process
millions of human lives are at stake so
the us fda
and other regulatory bodies in the world
want to make sure that the drug that you
want approved and launched in the market
is safe in order to demonstrate that
you have to take it through clinical
trials
and the clinical trials typically start
in what is known as
phase one clinical trials where you do
some healthy volunteers and demonstrate
that it is safe
then you move into a small alzheimer's
population maybe
500 alzheimer's population and show that
it is efficacious
and then you have to move it into like a
5 000 alzheimer's patients
that is called phase 3 to show that it
is not just
safe but also active in a larger
population
so this is what is known as taking a
phase one all the way through an
nda once you complete all this
you assimilate all that information into
a document
called new drug application or nda
you submit that to the fda the fda will
probably take six months to a year
to very carefully review it and then
say yes the drug is approved or not
that's really the end
so you will also and i will be talking
uh to you about that and i will also not
just talk about how to do
a phase one phase two phase three but
how do you successfully design a
clinical trial right
because clinical trials alone take about
70 percent of the budget
so if you're going to spend half a
billion dollars clinical trials probably
will take up two to three hundred
million dollars of that
so the whole idea is not to fail in a
clinical trial
all of the failures if you want to have
any should happen
in the beginning part and that's what
you will learn how do you select a
target
how do you validate it how do you design
a drug it is okay to fail at that stage
because it's not very expensive
but as a company we do not like to fail
in a later stages because it's so much
more expensive
right so i will tell you how certain
drugs were
successfully designed for example i will
tell you about a torostatin lipitor
it was actually the seventh product in
its class
being launched and yet it became the
front runner
why was that what was it about that drug
that made it competitively beat out six
other similar drugs and went ahead what
was the strategy what was the rationale
what was the clinical trial it's very
important that the clinical trial has to
be designed
from a market perspective also it's it's
not just enough to be able to
demonstrate that your drug is safe and
active
but you also have to convince a
physician
to prescribe it you know the physician
will want to know
why should i prescribe your drug versus
the three other drug that's already
there
right and that's all science driven
that's the science that goes behind the
commercialization so
i will spend a lot of time behind how
successful drugs were designed and i
will also showcase for you
how a bad clinical trial design
and i've gone through that also not only
have i gone through a successful drug
design
but in the startup company that i went
to after park davis
we actually had a drug fail in phase
three after spending 800 million dollars
so what went wrong what were the lessons
so i'll tell you about that as well
so um i think in summary what i'm trying
to tell you is that this is a very
exciting course for anybody who wants to
be educated
in this whole business of translational
research
slash drug discovery and as somebody who
has run large organizations such as dr
reddy's
i'll tell you one of the things i looked
for when i was hiring people was
what knowledge do they have of the drug
discovery business that they get into
right
so more likely i always like to
hire people that had more knowledge
about
what they were getting into than people
who had no knowledge at all so
some of you may be interested in a
career in the industry
so this course will educate you and what
it takes to
get to the industry so i'm very excited
to be part of uh this program
and really look forward to meeting all
of you
uh i believe my session is on the 22nd
of july
but you will also hear from some of my
colleagues sujeeth manson ajith kamat
ajit is also an industry veteran he has
worked at pfizer
and he's going to tell you about the
early phase you know how do you select a
drug and all that
so both parts are very important what's
called
the preclinical part that ajit is going
to address
and the clinical part which is what i'm
going to address so
i think i'm going to stop now but thank
you very much for your time and i hope
to and i hope and look forward to seeing
you
at these workshops